you don't have to minimize your browser
when you're watching YouTube videos and
I come by that stuff's hilarious what
you just got back from the dentist look
I know you guys are on Facebook most of
the day anyway I don't care I am too
look it was poked to you so we're not
having casual Friday anymore we're just
having that don't come in friday I
wanted to call it friday but uh in
corporate putting their foot in my ex I
know you guys have a nickname for me and
I like it fat val kilmer in the house we
don't mind if you use the corporate
internet to download pornography so it's
you don't how do you avoid it look what
came up when i looked for a chinese
restaurant that is not food just a lab
gum chewer yeah you're fired I noticed
you eyeing my wife at the Christmas
party I just want you to know she is
into you and I couldn't be happier weird
a warning get some rest she is a
mountain cat you know Oh what did you
want to be when you grew up certainly
not my best astronaut good choice my man
grace get me NASA I know Obama's hi NASA
the boss Jim Beam the bourbon